said a penguin this is what did he say
what did the penguin say to me penguin
oh I refuse penguin I did not sign up
Brad how's it going bros - today we're
playing trials fusion it got a new deal
seed and it looks [ __ ] awesome
I'm so excited to check it out I think
it's this one
the awesome adventure yeah
all right let's select our bike should
we go with that one no no no no yes
what do you mean bike not allowed it's
you're not even a bike not asking that
what why is it not allowing it go with
that one okay let's see if I still got
this
oh whoa whoa all right it's all gay oh
[ __ ] six like let me play normally Oh
God can I do it can I do it no oh I
could all right this is such a troll map
I seriously have no idea
uh-oh there we go nailed that nailed it
so the goal is to collect the blueprints
come on oh I forgot how bad I am at this
game no talent whatsoever
PewDiePie welcome to this channel ever
again all right Iran Iraq Wow oh god
that is making me sick
stop doing that my shrimps
oh my god I made it not really damn it
whoo
yeah awesome it's [ __ ] cool oh my god
what's happening
yes please be the unicorn oh my god yes
galloping sound violins level English
it's going yes video games so beautiful
what what is going on it's blows fire of
God's it blunts fire beautiful front
flap oh my god what is going on I can't
see what it Charla ports transforms
through time and space and blows fire
being written by a kitty oh my god this
is ridiculous can I shoot the gun can i
I'm scared of trying up I don't think
that was a good thing there we go
cat what are you going kitty keeps going
kitty kitty what are you doing kitty the
horse is so done it is just have any bad
yeah one of you can do tricks I'm scared
of trying that too oh my god Katie
through space right now god oh yeah know
how out oh hello
I like it yeah slap dad asked for me
alright
this is this is the best thing that has
ever happened to me come on such a great
idea
that's speed whoo yeah no damn it
no Abigail
whoo Oh God come on horsey what are you
doing horsey come back you see I'm not
done with you
oh god help
no that's horrible
Harry oh my god I can't keep up with
this this is ridiculous
yes Lee go kitty
whoo when will this map ever end
oh my god no back up calm down
kitty what are you doing how will I get
enough okay never mind
backflip yeah oh god front-flip
unintentional front flip horsey what are
you doing the future is not as bright as
we had hoped
go ho so you can still do it never mind
how I see
come on horsey make me proud
yeah Franz I'll take it any day best map
ever oh my god what role player what it
says more unicorns
is there more unicorns this is so insane
okay okay we're coming out of that I
guess yeah we're back we're back hi-c
near adventure adventures in the RPG
world oh my god
front flip nice friend oh my god ah come
on we can do this it's an adventure
oh god I need more speed I think no all
right I did it
he's so stiff the horse I like it's
tattooed Oh God and the fact that he
breathes fire him very useful the thing
is a pony or a unicorn I'm sorry I'm
sorry okay I'm scared of something weird
happening a cow can go horse a rad run
for your life it's not a penguin what is
this what did he say what did the
penguin say to me thank me now I refuse
penguin I did not sign up for a -
alright alright
nailed it woo oh my god this is amazing
I'm riding backwards with a pony what
else do you want in life what I was at a
crash I nearly cool hot magma front-flip
/ froak okay oh my god oh my god oh my
god I can't
the levels are so cool I gotta say it's
very neat very relaxing very nice I like
it go party we miss feet I bet there's
gonna be a boss at the end of this or
something that'd be cool
oh god what is this what is this kitty
there we said it was a damn wizard Oh we
saved the wizard it's like a quest Wow
all right where will you take me next
thing well I got poor kitty I feel like
he doesn't like it that much
oh we're in the mystical lands a
Forbidden Forest we must save the archer
rad pony rad to OCAD right quickly
oh my god what is going on no no stay
stay stay put pony there we go
yeah male that was [ __ ] awesome
front-flip whoo oh my god a lot of the
game all this plays itself it's in a
very like good way I guess oh my god
Brad pony yeah it's so smooth we saved
the are check and make the Kitty Archer
okay fine you know what I'm not gonna
bother questing it anymore I'm just
rolling with it at this point when you
take my next pick at the castle
there it is oh no not the Ming vases oh
god oh god oh god oh god all right we
did it
whoa this is so cool I'm amazed I
[ __ ] love this they need to make
older games with the pony and kitty
from now on I'll be thoroughly
disappointed now I really want to do
tricks on this I'll figure it out
figure it out there we go I was at a
crash marinus we saved we saved them on
yes Kenny what are you doing
kitty buddy - all right you know what
that's fine gold mantle damn I didn't
mean for that Wow oh there's one more
than gold all right this is [ __ ]
awesome the void welcome to the future
see a rip in time-space dive right in
thanks transfusion thanks all right what
level oh my god this is definitely a
time whatever I don't can't even
remember oh my god Bernie I'm scared oh
god did you see the tail Jesus Christ
Oh
Red Pony you probably shouldn't have
done the front flip their pony
come back here pony hold it goddamn it
this is not the tangent firebreath go
I feel like pony needs Alcott useless
son of a pony
Becca Pony back up that's a good pony
there you go that's how I said whoo yay
yay aah oh my god oh my god what is
happening
I'm scared other this gold again my god
I should go I'm ill gee look at that
look at it we got bass apalla why is it
even a question which vehicle I want to
use its Pony and Kitty for laughs for
laughs brush for laughs this changes
everything
everything in my life is a lie from now
on are we in the future now oh yeah we
are oh my god oh my god oh my god I
can't oh okay well that's cool oh my god
did that on purpose
see you later pony go far pony I'm proud
of you but do your front-flip pony yeah
did it this is so calm this map is so
chill I like it there you go breathe
some fire for me baby just do what you
got to do I appreciate it 100% 506 that
seems
at an oh damn come on pony
oh no pony you're doing it wrong kitties
you go pony ponies my new best friend a
lot of you I want to have your baby's
not throwing a baby's okay oh god not
again not a not again you did it again
there you go pony I wonder who does your
hair Pony it's it's amazing whoa okay
what's happening now the rocket Oh God
oh my god we're going to space pony I
hope you brought your space outfit pony
alright let's check out the celestial
disturbance yes go make me proud make me
bad I know you will what's this tattoo
is it's like a weird tribal who would
tattoo a pony
it's the pony just walk into the tattoo
shop in a hey give me some sweet-ass
tribal tattoos and get on it
Oh God oh how they cry it's so beautiful
go kitty okay there we go go kitty yeah
Oh God
look at that face there this the time
part up oh my god feel like kitty
doesn't like it oh my god I wonder why
alright here we go that's fun there
there wasn't that hard was it pony oh my
god oh god oh god
Koni yeah what ponies on fire this is
like a boss battle that's cool whoo I'll
just stay here got pony oh god what is
happening I don't know no one knows
really
ah got fun go honey
yeah yeah pull a paw
hold it space [ __ ] space I don't know I
did that yeah through did whatever that
was
yeah bronze I'll take the bronze hey
this is the boss battle come on man how
am I supposed okay alright alright
alright man this is awesome okay two
more level bras we can do it 100% 1000%
what I I don't know why I could send
them so many front flips look count them
nailed it you know oh come on gallop
gallop you but like you've never
galloped before pony
where am i okay yeah look at it look at
him go not anyone can do that except
party of course yes a lot of horsepower
there we go they say his horn was made
by unicorns that doesn't make sense
okay go beautiful are we going in the
one in the back yeah we are oh my god oh
my god what's happening seriously I
can't keep up sometimes too much for me
yeah that's how it's done you go pony
alright and Katie - of course I would
never forget you kitty I'm not sure I
was supposed to do that kitty
alright there we go it's kitty okay
kitty does not look okay not gonna lie
come on out let's listen how they were
pipes they're arias yes yes oh god the
pipes the damn pipes every time oh I got
grilled Wow
yes that's right pony you're beautiful
through the bottom gap onion yes yes
front flip
Oh God is this the boss battle
oh damn it is I think okay let's just go
with it
job pony okay careful now
yes oh it's a penguin what do I do here
I don't know what I'm doing I'm just God
come on come on come on come on yeah
yeah that's right penguin give me the
power
Archer kitty why are you kidding and
where's the kitty we did it Wow okay
last one what's gonna happen I don't
know velocity and said something what
but Kitty no no I love to you you were
so good to me
I noticed he has a piercing too that's
that's the thing okay well let's go with
the Fox bad I guess
let's see the point now I don't
understand what the meaning of life is
oh my god
Kitty's back what oh no we're not all
right
never mind sorry
oh my god no way a rig are we gonna do
what I think we're doing oh my god yes
[ __ ] yes this is so badass oh yeah yeah
no kidding and technically we're a
squirrel now but hitting out the spirit
of kitty this is ridiculous
this is gonna be so much speed oh my god
oh my god yeah yeah whoa
that's what I'm talking about
freedom yeah front flip okay I'm still
alive no I'm said I'm still good I'm
still good
damn it I know how I keep oh I get
points now I didn't get yeah that was
pretty cool
where am I going weed and so the lad the
space was forever fabulous thanks to put
a PI and his Bruce goddamnit I want to
play more what is this
alright I'm gonna have to end this
episode here if you enjoyed Bros please
leave a like go ahead and check out this
DLC I really really recommend it really
cool game awesome deal see so have some
fun thank you for watching and I'll see
you in the next one it's always stay
awesome